All right.
We're on problem number five.
OK, problem number five.
If m to the x times m to
the 7th is equal to 28.
They also tell us that m to the
5th, and then that whole
thing to the y power, is
equal to m to the 15th.
What is the value of x plus y?
x plus y equals what?
So this is really just a test
of whether you know your
exponent rules.
So what is m to the x
times m to the 7th?
So your temptation might have
been to say 7x, but no.
Remember, when you multiply two
numbers of the same base,
and the base is m, you
add the exponents.
So it's m to the x plus 7.
And they actually wanted to
tempt you to do 7x because
they actually use the number 28
here, which is a multiple
of 7, so they were tempting
you to do 7x.
But we know that you add the
exponents when you multiply m
to the x times m to the 7th.
And so we have m to the x times
m to the 7th-- oh sorry,
I wrote it down wrong.
It equals m to the 28.
Sorry, well you knew that.
Anyway, m to the x times m to
the 7th is equal to m to the x
plus 7, and that equals
m to the 28.
So the exponents have to equal
each other, so x plus 7 is
equal to 28.
x is equal to 21.
Now let's go here.
Here we have m to the 5th,
and then we're raising
that to the yth power.
So here we actually would
multiply the exponents, if you
remember your exponent rules.
So you have m to the 5y is
equal to m to the 15th.
So 5y must equal 15.
5y is equal to 15,
y is equal to 3.
So what's x plus y?
It's 21 plus 3, which
equals 24.
And that is choice d.
Next problem.
Looks like there's going
to be some drawing
for Sal in this problem.
I'll try my best. Oh, I thought
I was using-- undo.
Edit undo.
I thought I was using
the line tool.
OK.
That's my y-axis, draw
a straight line.
I drew a straight line.
That's my x-axis.
And then what do
they have here?
They have 19-- let's see,
1985, '86, '87,
'88, '89, then '90.
Let's see, 1985 is, maybe,
looks about 148,000.
So if this is 150,000,
1985 is here.
Let me just draw it all out.
1985, then 1986 is up
here at 160,000.
This is 140,000.
soon.
So 1986 is up here at 160,000.
1987 is a little bit less, 1987
looks like about 150,000,
I don't know, eyeballing
it at 156,000.
1987 is here.
1988 looks like a little
bit above 140,000.
1989 is between 130,000
and 120,000.
All the work here is drawing
what you hopefully already
have in your book.
So where was I?
Oh sorry, this is 1988.
1988 was a little bit
better than 140,000.
Ignore that one.
1989 looks like about 126,000.
Then 1990 is, I don't know,
112,000 or something.
1990 is out here.
And then if I were to connect
the dots, look
something like that.
And then let's read
the question.
According to the graph above,
which of the following is
closest to the decrease per year
in the number of homes
sold between 1987 and 1990.
So we're talking about from
1987, so it's from
this year, to 1990.
So how much did we decrease
in the first year, right?
The first year we decreased
by this much.
And I'm going to look in the
book because I don't know how
well I drew this graph.
But in 1987, it looks like
we're about 156,000.
And then as we go to 1988, it
looks like about 142,000 just
eyeballing it, right?
So this distance right
here is what?
It'd be 156,000 minus 142,000.
About minus 14,000, right?
That's how much we changed
over this one year.
And if I look at the choices,
there already is choice c,
which is 14,000, but let
me just do one more
just to make sure.
So if we want to figure out from
1988 to 1989, so we said
1988 is at 142,000,
where is 1989?
Looks like 128,000, I
would say 128,000.
And so 142,000 minus 128,000,
that's also 14,000.
And if we do the last one,
that's 128,000, and then this
looks something about
114,000 right here.
So this is also 14,000.
So the answer is c, 14,000.
Next problem.
Problem 7.
you Here we have this diagram
that shows up actually a lot
when you're taking the SAT.
I'll show you why.
This is a very common
thing you'll see.
A line like that.
And then they connect it here.
Now let's read the problem.
I already have suspicion what
they're going to ask.
So this is a, b, c, d, and e.
They tell us this is
perpendicular.
This is perpendicular.
This is x.
This is y.
In the figure above, ae and cd
are each particular to ce.
Fair enough.
If x is equal to y, the length
of ab is 4, and the length of
bd is 8, what is the
length of ce?
So we're trying to figure out--
let me draw ce, let's
have our gold in a different
color-- we're trying to figure
out this line right there.
And one thing I didn't write,
they told us x is equal to y,
so immediately that should
hit a trigger.
x is equal to y and this is a
90-degree angle, so we know
that x plus y plus 90 is equal
to 180, or that x plus y is
equal to 90.
And if they're equal to each
other, x must equal y, which
equals 45 degrees, right?
So this is 45, this is 45, and
if y is 45, what is this angle
going to be?
Well it's opposite to y, so this
will also be 45 degrees.
And this is a right angle too,
so 45 plus 90 plus this angle
has to equal 180, so what's
this angle going to be?
Well, that's also going
to be 45 degrees.
This also has to be a
45-45-90 triangle.
If you ever see a triangle where
one of the angles is 90
and the other is 45, the other
one has to be 45 because they
add up to 180.
And what we want to figure
out is this length here.
So I'm going to show you a
little trick, and this trick--
well, it doesn't always work,
it's not really a trick, it's
just a visualization exercise,
really-- we say, we want to
figure out this length.
Well that length, I'm going to
say-- I'm going to make the
claim, and I think you'll
believe this claim is the same
is this length, I'm essentially
creating a
rectangle-- is the same
as that length, right?
So if we figure out this length,
we solve the problem,
this light brown length.
And we also know-- let
me draw the bottom--
do we know the length?
Actually, we don't even have
to know this bottom line.
We don't know the length
of that bottom line.
We need to figure
out this length.
We know since this line is
parallel to this line.
We know this is a
90-degree angle.
Well, do we know
the hypotenuse?
Sure.
The hypotenuse is 4 plus 8,
it's this big red line.
And let me draw the hypotenuse
in a different color.
The hypotenuse, right here,
that's the hypotenuse.
Actually, I'm running out of
time, so I'm going to continue
this in the next video.
See